we've got breaking news and that is that
Jack tishera has been reminded in
custody a federal judge has ordered that
he is to remain in jail let's go
straight to our U.S correspondent Mark
Stone so he's been in court this
afternoon what was he charged with Mark
yes he appeared in court at the top of
the hour about 35 minutes or so ago
ushered in to the courtroom internet
this is all off camera so we won't see
any images of him but ushered into the
courtroom by U.S Marshals he was wearing
a a tan Brown jumpsuit there were at
least three members of of his family
sitting in the benches um in the
courtroom reserved for family reporters
inside the court said that they could
see
um the family members hugging each other
consoling one another before he was
brought in a male member of the family
was then seen crying when he made
contact eye contact with Tashira um as
the handcuffs were taken off um the
judge said he was charged with
possessing unclassified documents
pertaining to National Security and
possessing National Defense materials
now this carries um a prison term of 10
years three years supervised release and
for fines he has the right to a
preliminary hearing to determine a
probable cause we're told
um and and of course he has the right to
challenge and we expect he may well do
so um the the next court appearance will
be next Wednesday uh where there will be
discussion of bail
um at the moment he has been reminded in
custody he was placed back in handcuffs
at the end of the 18-minute hearing and
he looked at his family in the front row
but before being escorted back out of
the courtroom by U.S Marshals um there
you can see cameras there gathering in
that reflection um of the courtroom
Windows uh in Boston uh maybe uh his
lawyer will come out and speak maybe not
uh but the next appearance as I say will
be next Wednesday uh where where there
will be discussion of bail or not